if you want to get a small business loan
for your company you have to show that
you're beyond the startup stage and
already have significant traction with
your company
otherwise you're going to be wasting
your time they're going to reject you
and you might as well put that time into
actually growing your business
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and
today i'm answering a question from one
of my readers mo mo's awesome mo's been
asking tons of questions commenting on
all the videos i love you mo thanks for
all the work
so mo wrote in to say our small business
loans to get a small business loan our
banks less apt to approve the loan if
your company hasn't made any revenues so
mo absolutely you gotta understand where
banks are coming from banks are not in
the business of taking risk on
entrepreneurs
banks want to lend safe money to people
they want something that they can pull
away in case you can't pay your loan
back so they want your house or they
want an asset that they can take
if you don't have assets then there's
nothing for them to take if you're
trying to get a loan for your business
it's usually not possible until you've
already had three years of traction and
revenue
if you want to get a startup loan
and you're just getting started then you
usually have to do a personal guarantee
which means that if you if you don't pay
your money back they're going to take
your house they're going to take your
car they're going to take anything that
you have
in your possession any asset that you
have and it's gonna be based on your
credit score it's always dangerous to
take out a loan that has a personal
guarantee because they can come after
everything that you have if you can't
make that payment and you could end up
broke right nothing i hate spending
money till i'm making money and i hate
going into debt
i always try to fund my business from
the profits i put my hustle i put my
blood my blood my sweat my tears
everything into it my time my energy to
get some dollars out and once that
starts to happen i expand and maybe you
need money for expansion but i hate
going into debt especially when you're
first starting up i strongly advise
against it because it can sink not only
your business but your entire personal
financial future you make one wrong
business decision and you're stuck
paying this loan off for the next 20
years i know it's hard starting the
business and i know
one of the biggest challenges is getting
money to do it as much as possible try
to start a service try not to spend
money until you find a way to make money
you test your concept out on a really
small scale show that it works before
you invest your own dollars and
especially somebody else's dollars into
the into the business
if you're going to talk to a bank again
the banks are probably the least
friendliest to startups of any kind of
investor
they want to see the three years of
traction history revenue growth with
your company
and if they don't have it they're going
to take a personal guarantee and
whatever money you want to take out
that's life dealing with the banks
i hope you enjoyed for those of you
watching you liked the video please give
it a thumbs up below and i'd love to
hear from you i love seeing the comments
come in they make my morning every day
please leave a comment below and if you
have a question i'll do a video response
for you if you leave a comment
underneath thank you guys i'll see you
soon